why did it take so long for the
government to admit that kovid almost
certainly came from a Chinese lab
it isn't because scientists are just now
considering that theory plenty of
scientists have openly embraced the
Wuhan lab origin Theory from the very
beginning it isn't even that it's only
now that government scientists are
beginning to take the theory seriously
there have always been government
scientists on the lab League side of the
debate from the earliest days no
according to former CDC director Robert
Redfield the reason that the government
is only now beginning to admit the
likely source of covid is that the
government scientists who supported the
lab League Theory were previously frozen
out of the conversation
Dr Redfield did you agree in your
opinion with Dr Anderson's assessment at
the time that this virus did look
engineered
I was concerned because of the presence
of the fearing cleavage site that we've
talked about why did this virus have the
Arginine sequences for human they're not
bad it was very disconcerting to me it
looked like this virus was engineered
was this uh what you're observing and
speaking of is this something that would
be in line with gain of function
research and the capabilities it would
provide to the virus did you know of any
evidence that they had found within
three days from February 1st to February
4th to be able to confirm that it was
not created in a lab
as I mentioned earlier unfortunately I
was excluded from those conversations
which I found retroactively very
disappointed since I was obviously a
virologist and very engaged and I
actually had asked Jeremy Ferrar Tony
fauci and Tedros to have these
conversations and then to be excluded I
found
unusual
so the CDC director who believed that
this very likely could have been a lab
created virus he was frozen out of the
conversation by all of the top dogs in
public health in government including
Tony fauci okay that's what Redfield
says what does Dr fauci Dr fauci what
does he have to say about it
so let me ask you about what Dr uh
Robert Redfield is charging that you
frozen out that you didn't want him
there you didn't want him at these
meetings and that was deliberate you
know Neil I really feel badly about that
because I know Bob a long time he is
totally and unequivocally incorrect In
what he's saying that I excluded him I
had nothing to do with who would be on
that call that call was organized by a
group of evolutionary virologists in
order to discuss the possibility that
this might actually be a virus that was
actually engineered so I didn't put
anybody on the list of that call nor did
I take anybody else so it's really
unfortunate that in a public setting
like the hearing that Dr Redfield made
that absolutely incorrect statement even
if I hadn't before I now completely 100
believe Dr Redfield the reason is that
Dr fauci's classic tell came out when Dr
fauci uses phrases like totally
completely 100
incorrect as he did you might remember
when perjuring himself in front of Rand
Paul you are incorrect Senator you are
Inger well actually Dr fauci I have all
of the emails and documents right here
well uh well okay well all right never
mind oh the other things you say are 100
completely incorrect that's when you
know Dr fauci is lying though another
good way to tell when Dr fauci is lying
is when his lips are moving I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from tweef who says
I used to be a liberal and can confirm I
am happier now as a conservative many
such cases many such cases of that I
think it's kind of just built in to
those views of the world because the
liberal view of the world is a view that
is just generally kind of pissed off
about everything it's the view to quote
John F Kennedy that some people see
things that are and say why I dream
things that never were and say why not
which is the view of of the serpent in
the Garden of Eden that's that's what
Kennedy is quoting and he's quoting it
because liberalism looks at the world
looks at reality and says I don't like
reality I want this Fantastical
delusional thing that that seems really
great in my own head and when you live
according to delusion you're not going
to be very happy which was actually the
topic of my speech last night at the
University of Buffalo which had all
sorts of fireworks we'll get to in just
a moment if you were not able to make it
to that speech maybe you have a friend
who was at that speech you can call that
friend when you want to call that friend
you got to check out Pure Talk
right now head on over to puretalk.com
use promo code Knowles when times get
tough and money is tight who can you
rely on did you know Pure Talk saves the
average family over 900 a year when they
switch from Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
instead of paying a fortune with your
current sell provider every month cut
your bill in half with pure talk you can
get unlimited talk text and plenty of
data for just 30 bucks a month Pure Talk
is so sure you're going to love their
service they're backing it up with a 100
money back guarantee switch over to Pure
Talk in as little as 10 minutes while
keeping your phone and your phone number
they're us-based customer service team
makes the switch really easy besides the
fact that you're saving up to nine
hundred dollars a year Pure Talk is a
veteran-owned company that shares your
values and is the antidote to wireless
companies your first month is guaranteed
risk-free head on over to puretalk.com
enter promo code Knowles Canada wles to
save 50 off your first month that is
puretalk.com promo code Knowles Pure
Talk is simply smarter Wireless
the truth is coming out
the truth about all sorts of government
operations over the last few years
certainly the truth about covid which
you and I knew from the beginning you
know I hate to say I told you so and
many of you told miso and each other so
because it was so obvious from the
beginning that if you've got a major bio
lab down the street from where allegedly
this virus came from
and the virus has all these strange
features that we haven't seen before
probably did not come from a bad batch
of bat soup might have had something to
do with the bio lab then when you found
out
that fauci and the National Institutes
of Health were actually funding this
kind of research on back coronaviruses
funding the Wuhan Institute of virology
all of a sudden it seemed pretty obvious
but that's just starting to come out now
another lie that has been dispelled some
truth that's finally coming out now is
that what we were told about January 6th
the worst day in the history of the
Republic what you were told about that
was largely not true the handful of
videos you saw from John you already
sixth were were selected to be the most
violent scary videos you could possibly
see but then when you look at 41
000 hours of security camera footage
from that day
you find out that the image presented in
those videos that the liberal media
exclusively had had put forward did not
accurately reflect what happened the
clearest example of this would be that
the Q Anon Shaman you know the guy with
the horn hat
he he was not this Maniac revolutionary
leader running through the capital as
the police tried to chase him the police
escorted him through
they tried to open locked doors for him
and there were many such cases of that
so how do we know that we know that
because the Republicans one controlled
the house again which meant that Kevin
McCarthy was able to get control of 41
000 hours of security camera footage he
gave that to Tucker Carlson and Tucker's
investigators Tucker released that
footage coincidentally I was on the show
the night that he released it so I'm
sitting there in the green room I
usually don't pay attention to the shows
before I go on them and I'm Spellbound
I'm looking at this footage I said oh my
goodness gracious what we were told is
not really true so how is the White
House reacting to this green Jean-Pierre
says
that you need to stop believing your own
Lying Eyes
when you look at the depositions that
have been out there recently it even
States from Fox News leadership that
they do not see Tucker Carlson's show as
news or even truthful that is coming
from the fox leadership that's not
coming from me that is coming from them
and I also would quote I'll paraphrase
here what the chief of Capitol Police
said he said when you watch essentially
when you watch Tucker calls it as it
relates to January 6 it is misleading
and it is misinformation as with the
conclusion of what happened on January 6
the attacks that happen as you saw from
the president's statement
140 officers were injured nearly 140
officers were injured on that day it was
an attack on our democracy it was an
attack on our Constitution and you
cannot whitewash that Tucker Carlson
cannot whitewash that anyone who doesn't
see with their own eyes what occurred
cannot whitewash that and so the
president is going to stand with the
police police officers he's going to
stand for truth and clearly that is not
what Tucker Carlson believes in
if if you've seen them with your own
eyes you you can't whitewash that right
the issue for you guys is that right now
people are seeing this with their own
eyes for the first time they're seeing
lots and lots of security camera footage
and they're seeing that the story that
you presented is not true even down to
the police officers we were told police
officers were killed on January 6th that
was just completely made up and the
newspapers that reported that had to
correct those stories a lot of
newspapers making a lot of Corrections
in recent times but of course the story
runs on the first page the correction
runs on page Z ten thousands of many
fewer people see that but that's not my
issue here
my issue is not that the White House is
criticizing Tucker Carlson of course
that's going to happen it's not that the
White House is trying to spin and trying
to tell people not to pay any attention
to the New Evidence that's come out
my issue is that last line
it's Tucker Carlson he doesn't believe
in the truth
Tucker Carlson he's not on the side of
the truth
this coming from the libs
who constantly insist that objective
truth does not exist
that's my big problem with it this was
the topic one of the topics of my speech
last night at the University of Buffalo
the question of transgenderism the
question of feminism the question of all
these ideologies
it seems to me would be is it true or is
it false and yet whenever you bring this
up to a liberal they'll say oh
who cares they'll say who cares they'll
say what is truth they'll say whose
truth is it your truth is it my truth
they'll say there's no objective truth
that's a construction of the evil white
male patriarchy how dare you use the t
word in here
just just much Lamer versions
of the same cynical question going all
the way back to Pontius Pilate
who when Christ says I am the truth
Pontius Pilate says what is truth that's
what the libs say
and now Korean Jean-Pierre and the White
House has the audacity to say
Tucker Carlson doesn't believe in the
truth half this country doesn't believe
in the truth and it's not our half it's
not the conservative half we're the ones
who are just trying to to keep hold of
any semblance of the truth at all
while the libs say that boys or girls
and girls are boys and Up Is Down and
black is white
we're just saying no come on they'll say
no
in this modern world anything can be
anything
in the world of postmodernism in the
world of dairy da in the world of
Foucault in the world that students are
taught now they are educated to believe
that there is there is no such thing as
outside of the text it's a famous line
from from uh literary criticism in our
post-modern crazy era there's there's
nothing outside of the text there's
nothing there's no there's no objective
reality it's all just the meaning that
we make of it man it's all just whatever
you think you think you're a woman well
you're a woman you think you're a cat I
guess you're a cat who's to say
who's to say but Tucker Carlson doesn't
believe in the truth because he's
playing videos of what actually happened
for his audience hello pot hello pot
would you like to meet Kettle someday
you know who we're all gonna meet our
maker which is why you need to have a
will right now head on over to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles
according to a recent poll 62 percent of
Americans who think about their own
death a lot of the time do not have a
will
that doesn't make a lot of sense does it
that's a little like being afraid your
house will burn down but not having
homeowners insurance being afraid of
drowning but refusing to wear a life
jacket a will protects your wishes and
your family should something happen to
you and something will happen to you at
some point when you have a will you will
have peace of mind because you know that
you've done your best to protect the
ones that you care about I cannot stress
enough how important it is to write a
will and epic will is here to get you
started for just 119 dollars in as
little as five minutes epic will can
help you create your last will and
testament living will and even Health
Care power of attorney there's
step-by-step online form makes it
incredibly easy all you need to do is
fill in the blanks
I did not have a will for a very very
long time now I can rest assured that my
stuff and my money and most importantly
my kids will be taken care of when I am
gone go to epicwill.com use promo code
Knowles kwles to save 10 on Epic Will's
complete will package that is
epicwill.com promo code Knowles
I mentioned I was at the University of
Buffalo
last night had a great time really
really packed house
unfortunately we were not able to get a
larger venue so this speech was in a
venue that I think was
we were only permitted to seat 300
people we had we were allowed to do a
little bit of Standing Room on the side
but there were a thousand people outside
and half of the thousand people were
there screaming their heads off and
saying that they I should be killed and
shrieking all sorts of bizarre
obscenities and then the other half was
there just to come in and see the speech
most of the people who made it in to see
the speech were on the open-minded
inquisitive calm normal side of things
there were a handful of protesters
who were sitting there and then almost
the moment I opened my mouth they
started shrieking trans lives about her
trans lives matter and I said okay I
think I think I got the point
translating them the police had to try
to haul them out of there because they
just wouldn't wouldn't move and they
only knew about six or seven words so
there it was not a particularly
interesting dialogue
but we survived I you can watch the
speech right now on the yaf YouTube
channel the thing that most struck me
about going to the University of Buffalo
where there was this major major protest
pretty much every news organization from
the Buffalo area had come in there were
multiple there was a press conference
the day before about what I might say
that the University president had to
answer for this the Sunni the State
University of New York the whole system
of SUNY Schools Board of Trustees and
Chancellor released a statement about
how terrible I am which
did not speak very well of Sunni because
they apparently didn't understand the
basic meaning of my words but all of
this is I'm not I'm not just saying you
know it's a Big Show and you should all
show up to the next show though
obviously you should the reason I
mention all of this is because
there was so much press there was so
much publicity there was so much hubbub
and then when it got to the questioners
when it got to the Q a part at the end
the liberal critics who were in the room
didn't know what I believe
that was what was so striking
there could not have been more publicity
about the things that I say and think
that spurred all of this protest going
back last week to my speech at CPAC all
the way up to the event last night
people were being inundated in the
Buffalo area with information about what
I have allegedly said and believed And
yet when the questioners got up there
they had no idea what I thought
a guy gets up there he says Michael
you have said that uh sex and gender is
is purely a physical factor of
biological sex
now I'm just using that one example
because I've talked about it on the show
quite a lot how many times have I said I
don't think that human nature is only
about biology I think that man is body
and spirit I think the gender expression
is a legitimate way of talking about a
real phenomenon which is the the uh
metaphysical answer to our physical
nature and how often do I I talk about
that all the time I frequently say I'm a
little different than other conservative
commentators on this issue because I
think that the when people talk about
gender expression they're really just
trying to talk about the soul which is
obviously an important part of human
nature so I talk about this all the time
I'm not saying that these protesters
need to listen to every episode of my
show or even any episode of my show but
my question is if you've never listened
to a thing that I've actually said why
would you show up screaming protesting
saying that people have to kill me
why
Rush Limbaugh used to have this
people used to believe they earnestly
believed that they knew what Rush
Limbaugh had believed and had said
none of these people had ever listened
to one single episode of The Rush
Limbaugh Show so how did they think that
they knew what he thought because they
heard three words on MSNBC because they
saw some press release for Media Matters
half the time the the news clip or the
press release didn't even accurately
reflect Russia's words but they formed
this image in their mind and it just
wasn't true and and coincidentally this
was the topic
of the speech last night
on feminism and how feminism gave us
transgenderism since everybody's talking
about transgenderism now
the the transgender
activists
who say that we're killing everybody and
we're evil and we're terrible we need to
be shut down and shut up and locked up
they're convinced that we're wrong
we who hold to The View
that everybody held of human nature from
prehistory until approximately
five minutes ago we are definitely
totally hatefully wrong and they the
people who hold a view that was invented
within the last eight years as a matter
of public life they are totally 100
correct and they know that they're
correct because some man feels that he
is a woman or some woman feels that she
is a man but the question you've got to
ask is
is it possible
you're wrong
this was my question to I talked to some
protesters after well we'll hopefully be
able to get some of that video up I
talked to protesters after the speech
and they kept telling me things that I
believe that I don't actually believe
that I haven't said that I've regularly
contradicted
and I think if you can be so wrong about
that if you can be so wrong about this
relatively minor political event that
you've spent the last week wasting all
of your time plotting trying to get shut
down screaming making posters showing up
threatening people if you could be wrong
about that is it possible
that you are also wrong when you a man
say that you are a woman is that
possible that's my only question for
them now speaking
of sex and gender and people being very
very wrong I wanted to get to this
yesterday but we'll at least get to it
now Jill Biden the first lady of the
United States
for international women's day
gave out at International women of
Courage award
to a hulking dude
[Applause]
is a transgender woman who was kicked
out of classrooms barred for sitting for
exams refused job opportunities
subjected to violence and rejected by
her family but in the face of these
challenges she worked to end violence
and discrimination against the lgbtqi
plus community in Argentina
[Applause]
this is on a national stage and the rest
of the world is looking at us and we're
supposed to be the greatest most
advanced most serious most formidable
country in the world and we are an
embarrassment because right now we can't
even tell the difference between dudes
and chicks that's how profoundly
confused we are and for that fact alone
I think we have a right to say no to
this it's really embarrassing everybody
involved is embarrassed by it some in
our modern culture when we want to
overcome embarrassment we we just try to
push through it we say you shouldn't if
you feel shame you should just tell
yourself not to feel shame don't allow
anybody to shame you or no shame
is it can be a very good thing it's a
good feeling because it tells us maybe
we've done something wrong maybe we're
on the wrong path we should embrace that
shame and then
turn things around and go in the other
direction be like it'd be like turning
off all your nerve endings you say oh I
feel so much better now yeah maybe but
when you put your hand on a hot stove
you're going to set your whole body on
fire
you need those nerve endings you need a
little bit of that shame you need to
look at that and admit what we all know
is true which is
it's embarrassing
speaking of the way Democrats are
governing they're very very focused on
giving medals to men who pretend to be
women on the women's day not very good
at stopping a hundred thousand Americans
a year from killing themselves on drug
overdoses on drugs that are pouring over
the border from Mexico there was just a
vote on this we talked about the
fentanyl crisis last week
the fentanyl crisis not your regular
drug crisis
in the year 2000 about 20 000 Americans
died of drug overdoses in the year 2022
about a hundred and eight thousand
Americans died from drug overdoses this
is driven largely by fentanyl the
fentanyls coming from China then it goes
through Mexico the cartels send it
across are effectively open border and
then our friends and relatives and loved
ones kill themselves
not because they're going out and saying
hey I'll take a bag of fentanyl please
but because they're buying other drugs
that perhaps maybe they shouldn't be
buying but that would not otherwise be
deadly and then the drugs are laced with
fentanyl and then they overdose and die
the country is being poisoned at a rate
5x what we had in the year 2000 so
obviously we need to stop this right one
really basic way to stop this
would be to increase the penalties for
selling Fentanyl
right to increase the severity uh with
which we consider fentanyl so vote came
up
on the uh house Energy and Commerce
Committee to reclassify fentanyl as a
schedule one substance I thought it
already would be a schedule one
substance it's extraordinarily poisonous
unlike basically anything we've ever
seen in the country and the Democrats
shut it down
the Democrats shut this down
the
or they they at least tried to shoot the
stem they voted against it the
committee's health subcommittee approved
the bills that's the good news in a 17
to 10 vote every Democrat except for
representative Angie Craig voted against
the measure so why would they vote
against this thankfully the Republicans
have control of the house but why would
the Democrats vote against this well
because if you make fentanyl a schedule
one substance that's going to increase
mandatory minimum sentences for selling
this and the Democrats don't want to do
this
Democrats want to go light on drugs
Democrats want to go light on crime
Democrats want to abolish the prisons
this is the backwards World we're living
in Democrats are they're pleading they
say we need Mercy you shouldn't be so
judgmental we shouldn't be so harsh we
need Mercy
for the drug dealers killing people
but Mercy to the drug dealers who are
killing people right now is cruelty to
the relatively innocent people who are
purchasing the drugs and being killed by
accidental overdoses this is a line from
Adam Smith which doesn't tell the whole
story about mercy and justice but gives
you a lot to think about when we're
talking about this issue of the drug
overdose crisis
Mercy to the guilty is cruelty to the
innocent
which is why we cannot have a justice
system that is pure Mercy yes Executives
have the part in power that's good
because you can think of justice and
mercy not exactly as two totally
opposing forces but maybe as two
partners in a dance Waltzing same way we
think about Will and Grace not the gay
sitcoms from the 90s but will meaning
our Free Will and Grace being the free
grace of God not as opposing forces but
as partners in Waltz and unfortunately
right now in our country the way the
libs have governed
Mercy is is just doing a tap dance in
front of everybody Justice is completely
off to the side justice has left the
party and mercy is just doing a soft
shoe and unfortunately all of that Mercy
to all these guilty people is leading to
the deaths of a hundred thousand
Americans if we just close that border
you wouldn't even have to worry about
making fentanyl a schedule one substance
because the fentanyls all coming across
the border but no no no the Democrats
say we need Mercy Mercy for the illegal
aliens for the drug cartels for MS-13
you need Mercy for them well
Mercy to them is cruelty to the American
citizens who are supposed to have a
right to govern their own country Mercy
to them is cruelty to the women and
girls who are smuggled across the border
60 to 80 percent of whom are raped along
the journey Mercy to them is cruelty to
the Americans who are dying of the
fentanyl overdoses
they come as a result of our open border
who's really merciful who's really who's
really just
if the if this is not a good use of the
government
what is
I sometimes wonder this when we talk
about occasionally putting troops on the
border and that that topic has always
laughed out of the room you can't but
American troops on our Southern border I
say
if an open border
that is currently
[Music]
in an invasion that is being led by a
satanic criminal cartel called MS-13
among other cartels
if that is not a good use of the
American Military what is the point of
the American Military
we the American Military everywhere in
the world we can't put them on the
southern border no no we can the real
reason why we can of course is that
the elites don't want that because the
elites want an open border because the
Democrats want more voters and the
Republicans want cheap labor
at least the Chamber of Commerce
Republicans who have lost a lot of a lot
of influence in the Republican party
that's why if they wanted to fix that
problem they could fix it in two seconds
but the language they dress it up it is
the language of Mercy for these people
okay
well that's that would be uh that would
be big government yeah government exists
within its proper limits if this is not
within the proper limits of government
the government does not exist okay
this is a good opportunity for the
Republican Party
it's a good opportunity for the
Republican party because as I said
for most of my life the Republican party
was the party of the
big business
Chamber of Commerce corporate Rich Uncle
Penny bags Democrats they were the party
of The Working Man and over the last
seven eight years really because of
Donald Trump that has flipped that's no
longer the case so JD Vance
who ran on a relatively populist
platform for Senate JD Vance wrote
hillbilly elegy JD Vance who says we're
gonna be the party of Pittsburgh not
Paris Ted Cruz I think coined that line
and JD has run with it he has
suggested that we now take this
advantage and the the key place to take
this Advantage is this town that has
been totally ignored by the Democrats
and largely ignored by the Republicans
that town would be East Palestine Ohio
before we get to it
there's a line in Proverbs that says
without a vision the people perish that
is absolutely true not just in a
spiritual sense
but in a tangible physical sense too so
many people especially young men are
completely lost today because they don't
know what they want to achieve or how to
even figure it out Jordan Peterson has a
fantastic and surprisingly simple
solution to this in his new five-part
series vision and Destiny on daily wire
plus here is a clip
if I could have what I needed and wanted
accepting that I need and want certain
things what would that look like and
then you'll get a fantasy because that's
how the revelatory process works say
well
you know it might be not a very well
developed fantasy to begin with but it
doesn't matter get it down write it down
so I probably like this I'd probably
like this I might like this this would
be good it's like get it all down so
you're sort of provisional vision of the
beckoning future then the program asks
you do the reverse it's like okay
imagine this instead
you take all your bad habits these micro
personalities that are trying to sink
you and they get the upper hand and
where are you in five years
it's like while you're on the street
you're a prostitute you're a drug addict
you've alienated everyone you're a
narcissist you're successful but lonely
you're work obsessed I don't know what
your pattern of Temptation and pathology
is but you probably know so you outline
a little vision of hell it's like okay
I'm not going there and I'd rather go
here now you've got orientation right
between the ultimate bottom and the
ultimate up
the fourth episode of vision and Destiny
is out today new episodes are releasing
every week it's all exclusive for daily
wire Plus members
join now dailywire.com subscribe to
watch vision and Destiny
to briefly wrap up that point
JD Vance says that right now we have an
opportunity
to increase regulation on Railways JD
Vance
is co-sponsoring legislation with Josh
Hawley Marco Rubio allegedly John
Federman but obviously John Federman is
in a hospital right now Bob Casey and
Sherrod Brown to increase public safety
requirements for trains carrying
hazardous materials among other things
Republicans generally don't like
regulation because so much regulation is
unnecessary and burdensome and not very
helpful that doesn't mean we we hate
regulation per se we're skeptical of
government action that doesn't mean
we're against the government per se and
Republicans I think very foolishly have
ceded all of that territory to the
Democrats for 30 40 years so that they
can pretend to care about the people
when they in fact do not don't let them
seed that they have become
the party of the plutocrats of the
ruling class the the most powerful
interest in this country almost to a man
are Democrats okay that gives them a lot
of power but at least we can get the pr
win here and we can be on the side of
the people that's a nice place to be
speaking of the people let's talk to
some of the people the mailbag is
sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter code
Knowles Canada w-les you get 50 off your
first month let's take it away with the
voicemail bag
hi Michael so first off my fiance is a
cologne connoisseur of sorts and really
enjoys trying out different fragrances
and since he started listening to your
show he's always wanted to know what
clone you wear
um he always says that you can tell a
lot about a person based on what
fragrance they wear
um secondly on a more serious note I'm
curious what you think the role of the
government is on issues relating to
social media and the risk that they pose
to children and National Security at
large I know that politicians like
Senator Hawley from Missouri have
introduced legislation to ban platforms
like Tick Tock nationally and Institute
age limit requirements on social media
platforms personally I think something
like this is great but some of my
Republican friends think that it's not
the role of the government and it's
something that should be left up to the
parents
what do you think about this issue
thanks again for all you do love the
show
great question I'll take the second one
first then I'll get to the first one
yes some of the Republicans who just
have this reflexive response anything
the government does is bad they will say
the government has no role here in
social media but the sad fact is the
government has a profound role in social
media the government uses social media
as its censorship arm
we know this because of the Twitter
files we know this because of leaked
information out of Facebook from Mark
Zuckerberg himself we know for instance
on the hunter Biden laptop story and on
the Russia hoax and all the rest of it
that the doj the FBI were leaning in and
telling social media to put their thumb
on the scales for Democrats
we know that we know that social media
is permitted to exist because it
exploits a legal loophole in the
communications decency act a lot of
involvement from big government there we
know that the tech Executives have
regular meetings with the government
so the question is not will the
government be involved in big Tech I
mean we're talking about basically three
companies that control the flow of
information around our country obviously
the government's going to have some kind
of interest in that the question is not
will the government be involved the
question is how will the government be
involved right now because Republicans
want to bury our heads in the sand we we
allow only the Democrats to be involved
in big Tech and how big Tech operates
and we allow the usually liberal
Executives at Big Tech to control speech
in our Public Square which if you if you
control speech in the Public Square in a
republic means you control the whole
political order or are we going to
engage
it's not a good use of the government
right now
a an American citizen cannot buy tobacco
if he is under the age of 18. I actually
think they raised it
I think I believe as of a few years ago
an American cannot buy tobacco under the
age of 21.
but an American is allowed to go on to
tick tock Facebook Twitter Google all
the rest of it it's allowed to go on all
these social media platforms and have
their head poisoned a lot more than if
you had a few puffs of tobacco
at any age whatsoever that is obviously
insane it poisons people's minds it gets
them hooked on porn for one but all
sorts of other crazy ideas and terrible
things that are being presented to kids
so I think there totally should be an
age limit to that we're always talking
about banning Tick Tock yeah sure tick
tock's bad but what about Facebook what
about Twitter what about Instagram what
about the American ones
we don't like Tick Tock as Tick Tock is
controlled by the Chinese Communist
Party
but Facebook
YouTube Instagram I guess not Twitter
anymore but at least the first three
they're controlled by the American Libs
and they want to poison our kids Minds
with all sorts of crazy ideas just like
the Chinese do in some cases the
American Libs have crazier ideas than
even the Chinese Communists do on things
like gender ideology
so why are we not regulating all of this
yeah it's fine
regulate Tick Tock but don't let
Facebook and all the rest of them off
the hook either as to the cologne I used
to work alone a lot sweet little Elisa
on her health kick has convinced me that
fragrances are just poison they're not
quite as bad as seed oils but but
they're not great for you so I still
wear cologne sometimes but not all the
time and the cologne that I wear
usually is Armani Code
because
I was once a young Italian boy in New
York and we don't break our habits very
easily but the other cologne that I
recently ran out of was this colon a
friend of mine a a lawyer friend who's
done very well for himself he got this
as a gift from a client it's called Jew
lessons blue
Passion of the desert Shake
and a client of his guided in Abu Dhabi
or something and it was extremely
expensive I think it was something like
eight hundred dollars a bottle and you
would spray it on
and it didn't it didn't burn there were
no sometimes cologne's gonna have that
kind of nasty after feeling Raptor taste
you put it on and you smelled like you
were a Persian carpet that had been just
wrapped up inside an Armenian kitchen
that had been thrown in the the casinos
of Dubai I guess they don't have casinos
in the nightclubs of Dubai you just and
then and then wrapped up in a in a nice
Falafel Patty it was very very pungent
and I really liked it and I wish I had
more
so if anybody listen if anybody wants to
buy me 800 Arabian cologne I'm more than
welcome uh next question
hey Michael my name is Josephine and my
fiance and I were discussing our vows
the other day and I asked him his
thoughts on including and obey on my
side of house as it is more traditional
he is Catholic and I am converting to
Catholicism I'm probably one of the very
few Italians that is not Catholic
um I feel like we should include it
because I think it would be disingenuous
not to we're definitely more traditional
in our relationship and it's something
we value and I know that he values it
um he's thinking about it but I wanted
to get your thoughts it would definitely
ruffle some feathers on my side of the
family I don't think my mom would be
very pleased with it and I just wanted
to see how you would manage that and
what you think about including that in
traditional vows just to begin with love
to hear your thoughts and I love this
show thanks
great question sounds like you're
totally on the right track you don't
need me to answer this you already know
the answer yes of course include it
that's great
why would you not you want to your
husband wants to it's traditional it's
good you're totally on the right track
the only reason not to is because well
some feminist relatives might not like
it I was once at a wedding I'm not
joking where the wedding was being
officiated by ex-nuns so sort of had
I think not parted on great terms with
Mother church and the nuns were reading
a
a verse from The Book of Genesis
and about wives submitting to their
husbands and they edited the verse they
changed the verse during the wedding and
I thought you know when you're changing
the word of God because you don't like
it that's not a good sign that's not
where you want to be so that's great
it's very traditional I think it's
wonderful and furthermore it might
ruffle feathers
weddings should ruffle feathers I'm not
saying they should be antagonistic
events but a wedding is making clear
that you are leaving your mother and
your father and your husband is leaving
his mother and his father and you were
clinging to one another and you were
forming a new family
and you might do things a little bit
differently than your mother and father
might do and that's a very fine thing I
would not a lot of people want to cave
on the weddings and say I'll just do
whatever my mother-in-law wants or I'm
just gonna they I don't like it but
that's what my in-laws want to do no
no he who pays the piper calls the tune
so you might have to you know you might
have to Pony up a little bit more if if
whoever is paying doesn't like what's
going on but no this is the first act
that you two are going to have as a
married couple do it the way you're
going to live your lives okay next
question
hi Michael Arun here with a religious
question you have previously advised us
not to explicitly lie to others about
our covid-19 vaccination status and I'm
guessing that this advice is borne out
of your belief as a Christian that it is
unjustifiable to deliberately lie now
I've mulled over this advice Fair bit
because in the Hindu tradition we are
taught not to waste our Scruples on
those who are Unworthy of them this
comes from a vignette in the Mahabharata
in which a hero is engaged in single
combat with a villain and when the
villain's Chariot gets stuck in the mud
the rules of combat dictate that he must
wait for for the other person to free
himself but SRI Krishna God incarnate
tells the hero not to obey these rules
because the villain has stood by evil
his entire life and is deserving of
death I do think it is dishonorable for
someone to ask for my covid-19
vaccination status so I'm wondering if
you think that in such a case it would
be right for someone to lie and I wonder
if you as a Christian could perhaps tell
me how you might view this based on the
example from The Book of Joshua in which
Rahab hides two spies sent by Joshua and
even lies explicitly to the king of
Jericho about their whereabouts would
this not be an example of a case in
which it is right to lie for a greater
good thank you as always for your
thoughts
as always a fabulous question from Arun
really really good question
we're we're close up on the member block
so I'll try to give this as a pithy
answer and then maybe we can talk about
a little bit more in the member block
a good example from Rahab uh in in the
Bible and
a uh an example so striking because it's
so out of out of uh line with the rest
of the Bible and the way that lying per
se is treated that it's merited lots of
commentary over the years I think Saint
Augustine
said that what Rahab did was wrong when
she lied it was wrong she committed an
evil action but God
forgave that action the simultaneous
with it and in uh consideration of the
good that also came from that action
there have been lots of Bible
commentaries on this one way that it
could have happened though and one way
that one can kind of
work around these issues let's say you
know the Nazis show up and you're hiding
a Jew in your basement what do you say
is in my basement would be through
something called mental reservation
which is you could say
um the Nazis come up they say is there a
Jew here
and you say
there was a Jew here but he's not here
anymore
are you lying well it depends you're
using somewhat ambiguous language
because by here you could mean the room
that you're standing in and that you may
have been in that room but the Jew is no
longer there the Jew is now in the
basement
have you lied exactly
not quite sure that that would be one
option on uh mental reservation but I
would still have to stop short of of
this this line that we should not waste
our Scruples on people who are not
worthy of them you do not know you do
not owe a perfectly precise answer to
people who do not have any right to that
knowledge that they are requesting that
is true but it nevertheless is wrong to
tell a lie it is it is always wrong to
tell a lie and the morality of the
action of telling a lie is determined by
the action itself not by a a consequence
of that action uh that that would be if
we were to fall into a kind of
consequentialist few things that would
be taking it too far and that's the
truth Arun okay we've got to get to the
member block it is fake headline Friday
I've got my fake headlines I've got a
lot more not just voicemail bag
regular written mailbag we got
everything man I still have a little bit
of coffee we're good see over there at
the member block if you were not a
member yet
delaware.com Knowles use code nulls
and get two months free at checkout see
you over there
[Music]